you want to be the president of the
United States right right you want to so
yes why why why is a good question let's
start with that well you know I didn't
spend my lifetime thinking that I should
be president or wanting to and um it was
really during the pandemic I just
started thinking because I was being
very very heavily censored during the
pandemic so I was removed from Instagram
I was um I was you know I had been on at
at one point I had had a
very uh you know big presence on
mainstream media I was publishing very
often the New York Times and all the
other mainstream newspapers and um and I
was you know I was a frequent guest on
on every side on Fox and on CNN MSNBC
and all the
networks and then when I started saying
things that were controversial about the
lockdowns and other things
I was censored very
heavily and I was removed my Instagram
account that had almost a million
followers on it was
removed um
and I was you know I I had a a book
out at on Anthony fouchy that was not
didn't get a single review although it
sold a million copies within three
months it was the biggest bestseller of
the Year 17 weeks the as seller and yet
it didn't get a single review and I
wasn't allowed on any television show to
talk about
it oh I was watching a lot of this and I
and then the war started um and I you
know had a lot of objections to the war
in
Ukraine and I but I couldn't talk about
any of these things so I I thought you
know if I was running for president I
have a big enough following that I could
qualify for the debates and I could
raise enough money that they'd have to
let me on the debates and um and let me
talk to the American people for the
first time and then but it wasn't a real
it wasn't like a notion that I was going
to do it was just an idea and and a guy
called uh Jeremy zogby who runs one of
the biggest polling firms in the
country contacted me I'd never met him
before but he had been polling my name
just throwing my name into a lot of
different poles across the country and
the results were were really astonishing
despite the fact that I'd had thousands
of Articles written about me all of them
negative literally for for five years I
didn't get a single good article and I
had thousands and thousands of attacks
and
mischaracterizations my assumption was
that among the general public my polling
would be as low as you could get in the
negative
probably and but it wasn't it was
actually in terms of popularity it was
ahead of anybody that they were
polling which astonished me and the
polling and and I've I've read a little
bit about the polling the polling was
isn't it amongst Independence though
right no this was polling I didn't know
he was doing this polling and he did he
did several different kinds of
polls he did poll he pulled me among
Democrats among and then among the
general electric to see
to see how I would do in a primary right
and then to see how I'd do in a general
election and then just favorability
rating ratings my favorability was ahead
of it was the number one person there
was about 28 people like des santis and
Trump and Biden but they also had Pope
Francis on there they had Elon MK they
had Greta thornberg and you know people
who were pretty
popular my popularity my favorability
rating was higher than anybody's which
shocked me and I thought well you know a
lot of these people who they're asking
probably think they're my dad that I'm
my dad right there's probably a number
of people your name your brand is right
who you know because anybody who read
any article for that fiveyear period
would have a negative point of view of
me so then we did some more he he was
trying to convince me to run which I was
hadn't really didn't have
any aspiration no and then when the war
started um I was I was pretty alarmed
that the Democratic party had now become
the proar party the Democratic party was
always an war and I saw why it was
happening that you know their funding
was all coming from rathon and General
Dynamics and uh and lock and owing and
northri Grumman and black rock and State
Street and Vanguard all of these big
companies that make they're living make
money you know part of the
military